INSTRUCTOR 1: Welcome to
"Getting Started on Android."
This is a crash course
in Android development,
and this short video is meant
to show you exactly how easy
it is to get started.
Whether this is your 100th
startup or your first time
coding, there's something
to learn for everyone.
Before you build, you'll have
to make important decisions
with your team, like
whether to build
an app or a mobile website and
the kind of user experience
you want to create.
You should also ask
what you want your users
to be able to do
with what you build.
Once you've made
these decisions,
bring your wireframes along
and let's get started.
KATHERINE KUAN: If you
haven't installed it yet,
take a moment to do that now
using the detailed instructions
provided in the link below.
Open up the Android
SDK Manager to see
what tools, platform
versions, and components we
have installed.
At the time of this recording,
the Android L platform
is available, but it's still
in Developer Preview Mode.
That means it's
subject to change
until the official release.
And you can't upload
your app to Google Play
if it's targeting this
L platform version.
Hence we want to use the
latest stable platform version.
Deselect all the other
packages and just choose
the ones for API Level 19.
We want the SDK, as well as the
system images for the emulator.
We also want the
Android Support Library
for backwards compatibility.
We picked the latest version
of Gingerbread at API Level 10,
because it contains bug fixes
that API Level 9 doesn't have.
Then we go ahead and click Next.
We're going to pick
the Blank Activity
with Fragment template.
For background
context, an activity
serves as a presentation
layer for our UI.
And the fragment
within it represents
a behavior or portion
of the screen.
Now for the moment
you've been waiting
for-- let's run the app by
clicking on this button.
It will prompt us
to choose a device.
Without a physical
device, we can
use the emulator, which is
included in the Android SDK.
Currently, it says that there
are no Android virtual devices
available, so let's open up
the AVD Manager to create one.
Then click New.
By creating an AVD, we can
configure an emulated device
with the Android
platform version
that we want to test on, as
well as hardware options.
When it loads up, we see our
Sunshine app with the words,
"Hello, world."
And then we'll need to
enable USB debugging.
This can be found in Developer
Options in the Settings app.
To find the secret menu,
go to the Settings app.
Scroll down to About phone.
Then go down to Build number,
and tap on that seven times.
Then, when you go
back to Settings,
you'll see the Developer
Options menu appear.
Now, in Android Studio,
you can hit the Play button
to run the app on your device.
In the Device
Chooser dialog, you
should see your
connected device.
To prevent the dialog
from popping up
in future times, check this box.
Then hit OK to continue.
Within a few moments, you
should see it on your phone.
IZABEL GREY: In design,
we have a technique.
It's called wireframing,
or low-res wireframing.
Imagine there's a task that
your user wants to complete.
So for this example, it's--
I'm hungry for cookies.
I want to get some and eat
the cookies, basically.
So then you think
about, what steps
does your user need to go
through to complete this task?
So this is an easy example,
because we only have one task.
So the steps would be sign in,
decide which cookies you want,
pay for your cookies,
and then eat the cookies.
So when we write out
each of these steps
at a high level like
this, each of these steps
is kind of like
a Java interface.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
When you think about
a Java interface,
it's something that doesn't
have any implementation.
So you're not really thinking
about the low-level details.
But you're thinking
about the contract
that interface has with other
interfaces and classes--
which, in this case, if
you look at the steps,
it's how these steps
connect with each other.
So instead of focusing on just
one step and nothing else,
you're really thinking
about the big picture.
KATHERINE KUAN: This
has the correct flow
for how the user will
interact with the app,
but it doesn't have the final
visual look and feel yet.
We'll build this
up step by step,
starting with the Main Activity.
Then we'll move onto
the Detail Activity,
and then later, build
up the tablet UI.
INSTRUCTOR 2:
MainActivity is launched
when you start the app.
At the bottom of Main Activity,
we have PlaceholderFragment.
PlaceholderFragment.
was generated by the template we
used when creating our project.
A fragment is a modular
container within your activity.
In later lessons,
we'll look at how
to use multiple fragments
in a single activity.
And we'll actually explain
why we're using them at all.
But for now, our activity
contains just this one
fragment.
So here, in
PlaceholderFragment, is
where we reference our UI layout
resource, called fragment_main.
This XML file lives in the
resources, res, directory
of our project folder.
You can see other kinds of
resources here besides layouts,
such as design assets,
or drawables, or strings.
When our activity
runs, it creates
this PlaceholderFragment, which
then inflates the XML layout
resource, converting
everything in the XML file
to a hierarchy of view
objects in memory.
By holding Control or Command,
depending on your operating
system, and clicking on this
reference to fragment_main,
Android Studio will drop us
right into the Visual Layout
Editor.
Once we're inside
a layout XML file,
we can switch between the Design
tab, where we can drag and drop
new UI elements and modify
the layout visually,
and the Text tab, where
we can see and edit
the XML that defines the
layout and UI elements.
KATHERINE KUAN: In order
to build a UI in Android,
we use views.
View are rectangles
on the screen,
and we may or may not see the
borders of that rectangle.
Essentially, a view handles
drawing and event handling,
and all the basic
widgets in Android
extend from this base class.
The Android Design Guide
has visual examples
of these basic building
blocks of apps.
INSTRUCTOR 2: Imagine
spending hours
crafting the perfect layout.
What happens to that layout
when you rotate the device
into a landscape orientation?
Or when it's run on a device
with a much larger screen?
The good news is
that Android provides
excellent tools to
help you with layouts.
You'll want to understand
them to make your app look
amazing across the wide
variety of phones, tablets,
and other devices you'll
want your app to work on.
Today, the lines between phones
and tablets are disappearing,
so it's important to think
about how your UI will
scale in our multi-screen world.
Don't be overwhelmed.
Just like designing responsive
layouts for the web,
build your layouts to
be reasonably flexible,
or within a common device size.
Then you can set breakpoints,
providing alternative layouts
for those various sizes.
RETO MEIER: All externalized
Android resources, everything
from strings, to layouts,
to drawables and animations,
are all stored within
your project's res folder.
You've already been putting your
strings in the strings.xml file
stored in the values
folder, and you've
been putting your layouts
into the layout folder.
And you know to
reference your resources
using @ notation within both
your XML or within the code.
And then at run
time, Android will
insert the appropriate
resource for you.
So far, so good.
And here's where things get
a little more interesting.
Android allows you to
create alternative versions
of every resource
by placing them
into folders with
different qualifiers.
We separate each of
those using a hyphen.
And we can add those
qualifiers based on anything,
from language and/or dialect to
whether the device is docked,
the type of touchscreen, the
pixel density of the display,
the orientation of the
screen, and most importantly
for a responsive design in
particular, the smallest
available screen with which
you can support that layout.
INSTRUCTOR 1: This was a
lightweight introduction
to Android development.
You can learn more by
checking out our full Udacity
course to get the full content,
or by visiting the Android
developer site.
If you're ready to
distribute and monetize,
you should check out
our great resources,
including quality guidelines
and go-to-market processes
for startups at g.co/launch.
All the best, and happy coding.